meantime we have some very big and
dramatic news from the world of football
which is that uh chelsea football club
have just sacked their manager thomas
tuckle obviously uh thomas tucker
oversaw last night's unexpected defeat
one nil they lost in the champions
league to dinamo zagreb that was
actually thomas tucker's 100th game in
charge of chelsea and he said after the
match were clearly not where we should
be and that is on me so he was accepting
an element of culpability for chelsea's
defeat last night they've made something
of a lackluster start to the season in
the premier league it has to be said as
well and that's despite the fact of
course that it was the biggest spending
club in the premier league during the
close season a lot of money lavished on
new players the club of course under new
ownership now after roman abramovich was
forced to sell following russia's attack
on ukraine the new u.s backed consortium
led by tob bowley clearly uh somewhat
impatient with progress under uh mr
tukel despite all that high spending as
i say so breaking news there thomas two
calls sacked by chelsea